[la musique]
[applaudissements]
Le mémorial de Rzhev est un autre symbole de notre
souvenir commun symbole d'admiration pour
grand exploit désintéressé
soldat héros soldat libérateur
le soldat du vainqueur le soldat qui a sauvé
L'Europe et le monde entier du nazisme
le temps n'a aucun pouvoir sur cet exploit et il
ne doit jamais être oublié et
lit d'autant plus usé et enduit
falsifications, nous ne permettrons pas cela
nous ne permettrons pas de minimiser l'importance du grand
victoire pour déformer la vérité des événements de cette
temps et réhabiliter le nazisme autrement
la tragédie peut se répéter
Biélorussie-Russie
payé avec des millions de leur vie
citoyens pour la paix sur terre
absolument unis dans cette quête